some 200 amazon employees tell the new
york times they had to face
unfair working conditions during the
pandemic a time when the online retail
giant had record profits in an article
out this morning those current
and former workers claim amazon relied
too much on computerized human resources
and had a mindset that encouraged
turnover in its warehouses
we asked amazon for a response but have
not heard back according to the article
amazon acknowledged some some issues to
the new york times with inadvertent
firings
loss of benefits job abandonment notices
and
leaves amazon argues those problems and
some others chronicled in this article
were
outliers the company has given raises to
its workers and introduced new safety
initiatives and diversity plans
we hear we have pulitzer prize-winning
new york times correspondent jody cantor
who's been working on this story
for nearly a year she's also a cbs news
contributor this is the first interview
jody that you're doing about this
article which just was posted
jody i mean throughout this pandemic
year we've been hearing about all these
issues at amazon and then in the article
you talk about how
the turnover is so high they basically
replace the equivalent of their entire
workforce every eight months what's
going on there
it all goes back to the original vision
that jeff bezos had for this company
and we quoted actually some brave former
executives who went on the record with
us to describe his philosophy
and express their concerns about how
it's playing out
he wanted quick turnover because he
wanted people when they were fresh and
new he felt that
he he to paraphrase him he almost felt
that human beings were inherently
lazy and so he wanted to keep people
moving
through his system and also
intentionally limited upward mobility in
the warehouses it's very hard
to start at the first level at amazon
and then progress
up very high but he may not have
expected that he'd end up having as many
employees as amazon
now does well part of the issue is scale
it's now this
gigantic company and i think the
question of the investigation in many
ways is
how come amazon can be so precise with
packages
and yet treat people so differently and
is this is this what powered amadon
amazon's success is this their secret
does it work really well
or is it actually an impediment to the
company's survival some of those
executives are
actually worried that amazon could run
out of workers because they are burning
through workers so quickly
so they get to the point where everyone
in america available to work for amazon
has already done
so and they're looking for a second
re-up a part of what the article lays
bare and makes very clear
is how well amazon tracks its own
employees not only the packages but
it tracks things like time off task what
does that kind of tracking do to the
culture at amazon
so it is true that in in most of these
jobs in the warehouse you are tracked
every single second when you pause
a computer is noting that it's almost
like an attendance system
within an attendance system now you may
have an excused reason for pausing
but you have to go to your manager and
ask them to code that in
we write about a woman named dianna
santos who was an excellent performer
she she had lots of praise she had one
really bad day in which a series of
things some of which were beyond her
control went wrong
she was fired for one bad day
after we went back to amazon with that
story and asked them many times about it
they did say they are going to change
that policy what does that do to the
morale of the workforce
well there's a lot of frustration at
amazon as you know and i think when you
meet the characters in this story they
help
explain it some of them feel that and
this is especially true i think of
workers of color
black workers who are fired at jfk at
least back in 2019 at a much higher rate
nearly 50 percent higher
than white employees felt like i give
this company my best effort and there's
no
reward for me even if i excel on this
productivity software even if i work
really fast there is no path to progress
to me in in one of the most successful
organizations of
uh our era and that's that's the staten
island facility where there were
protests during the pandemic
yeah this is really this is also a
narrative about characters
wrestling with the pandemic year in this
particular place called jfk8
this you know jfk it got us a lot of our
packages when we were homebound i think
we all relied
on these workers even if we didn't know
what jfk 8 which is the only fulfillment
center in new york city
really was it's also heartbreaking in
the piece
learning about employees who were trying
to take leave and thought they were
above board with the company
and then are discharged nonetheless how
does that happen this is one of the most
striking findings
people were mistakenly fired just for
trying to take leaves
and you know the story is about what
happens when you have this giant system
that's
very highly automated there's a big
question about whether amazon has
invested
enough in these systems and people would
get these
even just for applying for a leave
sometimes you could get a job
abandonment notice as if you had done
something wrong
and also one of the most poignant
stories uh in the article
is about a woman named ann castillo her
husband was a very
long time very loyal well-liked amazon
employee
he got very sick with coronavirus
he suffered brain damage his condition
is very serious
and yet she had these questions about
you know why
is the company like do they even know
what is happening
to my husband and it led her to ask are
their workers truly replaceable to them
it's an unfortunate uh possible reality
and you're holding amazon accountable in
your reporting
i think the question now is whether
customers will in some way hold
amazon accountable they are so big and
so good at what they do
they're almost unavoidable in the
marketplace jody cantor thank you very
much we appreciate it